rick porcello will go to work
and make his 10th start of the year the
first time porcello faced the phillies
this year in philadelphia it was
mccutchen who had a big home run to
spoil
their hand play by davis and he's out at
first base oh jd davis with a beautiful
pickup and then using that strong arm to
gun down mccutchen for the first down
nicely done 3-2 coming
and he waves at the slider for strength
three and so port solo who's had rough
first innings this year as himself a one
two three first tonight jake arrieta had
one of his best starts of the year
against the mets just a couple of weeks
back in the 02 pitch on the way swinging
a miss
cano has never had much luck against
arietta and that continues with his
first a b tonight
no two coming to kingery
and he tries to hold he takes strike
three called and poroso gets him looking
at the slider for the second out
one-two pitch swung out and missed
strike three blew a fastball by him at
93. and that retires the side
swing and a miss
that's a good out
second strikeout for jake so alonso now
batting
222 for the season one for 11 lifetime
the base is loaded with
[Applause]
optima out to shallow center fields
roman quid is under it and the inning is
over he's dodging in and out of traffic
today jake garrieta is andrew mccutchen
robbed of a hit on a tremendous play by
jd davis his first time up
and mccutchen goes down on the slider
and corcello
has his fourth strike out of the night
we'll see ramos the hitter
swinging a miss
excellent inning for jake garrieta side
is retired three strikeouts for jake the
second walk of the inning the bases are
loaded
and hazely will pinch it
but his lead off in the count one ball
one strike
that one's lined into left center field
of base hit one run is in here comes
kingry he'll score to two-run pitch it's
single for adam haisley off the bench
and the phillies take a two-nothing lead
he starts his third time through the
batting order brandon nimmo leads off in
the fifth and brandon drives one out to
right field that ball is out of here
brandon nimmo slugging the first pitch
of the fifth inning into the seats in
right field for his seventh home run of
the year to cut the phillies lead in
half
you tied him up with a slider
sharply to third and it knocks the glove
off j.d
that was unbelievable it knocked the
glove right off his hands
uh feet have thrown him out man that's
where you just shut it down
not didi gregorius
deep to right field forget about it it
is gone
off the pennsylvania lottery side
a two-run home run for deeney
and the phillies take a 4-1 lead
the ball in one strike runners lead off
and that hit him
so that'll load the bases up and jake's
hurt
yep he just grabbed the back of his
right leg
and now he's limping around the mounds
he is walking right off the field jojo
romero is coming in but not before john
he finished the red bull and then
smashed it
[Music]
ground ball out towards shortstop should
be two there's one and
two what a pick by alec balm
wow
he needed to pick it
and the side is retired one pitch
for jojo romero no match for jojo though
opposite way flagged down by bug through
the second for one back to first in time
a double play
three four three on the double play
he made the right decision he almost
stepped on the first base bag but
decided to go to second
to get the force
back-to-back innings and it with a
double play you know base hit right here
and it's a 4-3 game
over toward third segura backhand
and he's got mcneal right on the top of
the helmet
what a break for the fills
that mcneal
went toward third the run does not count
now hector maris is on to try to pick up
his fourth save
[Music]
he got him 95 on that fastball and the
bills have taken game one against the
new york mets back over the 500 mark
as they win it today by a final score of
4-1